- Yeah, so first,
I'm just gonna give you a
little bit of introduction.
So my name is Kelsey.
I grew up in Texas near the Dallas area.
Did my undergrad at the
University of Texas in Austin.
And I knew I was always
interested in biology and science.
And I actually got to do my
first research experience
as a high school student.
So I worked in a lab in
Dallas, studying colon cancer.
And I was introduced to cell culture
and mouse models in cancer research.
And I knew that I wanted to go on
to do cancer research based on that.
So I went to college,
I got my bachelor's in science.
And then I headed off to the NIH
where I worked for a year
in a super resolution microscopy lab
before heading to New York City,
which is where I did my PhD
at Memorial Sloan Kettering Cancer Center.
And that's where I became involved
with RockEDU in their science outreach,
and why, even though I'm
currently in Michigan,
I'm connected to you guys in New York.
And so in my current lab,
like I said, I'm a post doc.
This is actually my second post doc.
My first post doc,
I was studying a type
of pediatric bone cancer
called Ewing sarcoma.
And now, I'm studying colon cancer.
And I'll get more into
what I'm actually doing research wise,
but that's kind of my career trajectory
and all the different places
I've gotten to do research over the years
and how I've grown my skills.
And so just to get started,
I wanna ask you guys a very,
very important question,
which is the first poll.
So I'm curious which you
guys consider to be better,
pie or cake.
Okay, it looks like we have 16 votes in.
I think we're waiting for a few more.
I'm glad you guys find this as
important a question as I do.
So let's say another 20 seconds
just for a few more people
if anybody else wants to answer
or if they want to provide
a reasoning in the chat,
that's cool too.
Also, if anybody has any questions already
or something they want to ask, feel free.
Okay.
- [Student] Now, I just
wanna say one thing,
if you say pie is better
than cake, you're wilding.
You're out of pocket, I'm sorry.
- [Kelsey] So it looks like cake won.
So 70% to 30%,
which I find personally surprising
'cause I'm in the pie category,
but it's interesting to
see everybody's reasoning
and where everyone has fallen.
Yeah, cake won.
Okay.
- [Student] Can I give a reason
why I think cake is better?
- Sure, we'll have one cake reason.
- [Student] Let me explain.
So, with pie, it's like you
have such a limited thing.
But with cake, you've got
stuff like cheesecake.
You've got red velvet, which
is the god of all cakes.
So you have so many different options
compared to how pie is.
Like, you've got apple pie.
I won't get you wrong,
you do got sweet potato pie,
you do got pumpkin pie,
but like with cake,
you're just more stacked
and overpowered over there,
in my honest opinion.
- (laughing) That's some
very interesting reasons.
I guess I have to sample some more pies
in order to fully have a
good scientific experiment
with a large sample size.
- [Student] I'd really appreciate that.
- (laughing) So, so yeah.
So now, I'm going to
switch over to my phone.
So just give me a second.
And we're gonna go on a lab tour.
Okay, so can you guys hear me now?
- [Odaelys] Yes, we can.
- Okay, cool.
So I'm currently, like I said,
I'm currently in the cell culture room
just 'cause with COVID,
we have some space restrictions.
So this way, I'm out of the way.
But I will take you guys
out to the rest of the lab.
So, you can see here is like some benches.
So this is where we work.
So people are doing various experiments.
So you can see more bench spaces.
We have lots of fridges
because we have to store
things at various temperatures.
This is a room where we
do a lot of experiments
that involve running gels.
So if we want to like
look at protein levels,
or RNA levels, or DNA levels,
this is the room where
we do a lot of that work.
We also have our (indistinct).
This is where we work with mice
and they're a good model for cancer
'cause they're similar to humans,
but you can obviously do things with mice
that you can't do with human subjects.
Yeah, so this is kind of our lab space.
We have another cell
culture room over here.
You can see we have someone
currently working in the hood.
So she is splitting some cells.
You can see how it works.
This is Christina.
- Hi, Kelsey.
How are you?
- Good.
Yeah, so basically,
the basic components
of a cell culture room
are the incubator,
the hood where you work
to keep things sterile,
and your microscope.
So we're gonna head back to
the other cell culture room
where I'm gonna actually get some cells
that I'm gonna be able to show you guys.
So as I said, this is the hood.
And basically, it works
by you raising up the sash
and then you can work inside of it.
And inside is sterile,
outside's not sterile.
This is how we prevent
ourselves from getting bacteria
(indistinct) contamination.
We grow our cells in an incubator.
So this is an incubator.
We keep it at 37 degrees Celsius,
which is about 98.7 degrees
Fahrenheit or body temperature.
So basically,
these cells are used to
growing in a human body,
so we keep them at the same temperature.
So you can see,
we have a whole lot of
different plates of cells
all throughout here.
So I'm gonna get some of my cells out
and we're gonna go next
door to the microscope.
So normally, I would look
at it on this microscope,
but it's a little hard to show via phone,
so we're gonna go next door
where there's a camera
connected to the microphone.
Sorry, a microscope, not microphone.
So this is the microscope
and it has a camera connected to it.
So on the screen, once
I turn the light on,
we'll be able to see cells.
And so I have a few
different types of cells
for you guys to look at.
So this first one is a
colon cancer cell line.
So you can see that this is
what the cells look like.
They're growing in a dish.
You have this red liquid on top,
which is just their media.
Basically, it has all
the nutrients they need.
But the cells are really small,
so in order to see them,
we need the microscope.
So we're gonna turn the light on
and then we have to focus on them.
So you can see these are our cells.
So basically all of these little shapes,
they're kind of like a weird triangle
or like an elongated diamond.
And so we have all the different
cells that are growing.
And then we have the cell,
like places where there are no cells.
And so this is a colon cancer cell line.
So it grows attached to the plate.
So it's adherent.
So you can see as I move
the plate, the cells move.
And there's a few cells
that are kind of floating.
Those are dead cells.
On the other hand,
I also have this other
cell line right here,
which is a suspension cell line.
So it grows in suspension.
It doesn't adhere.
It doesn't attach to
the bottom of the dish.
And so you can see when I move
that basically the cells
move back and forth.
And also, there's a few different levels
at which I can focus.
And so these are a cell line
that were made from red blood cells,
basically the precursors
to red blood cells.
And so what they did
was they added in a gene
that allowed the cells to grow forever
'cause normally, your cells only grow
for a certain amount of time,
and then they stop.
And by adding this gene,
we can grow these cells forever
so we can use them in the lab
in order to study red
blood cell differentiation.
We can see how if you take something away
or you add something different,
how that affects differentiation.
But you can see that these cells,
like I said, are suspension,
whereas the other ones were more attached.
So for both of these,
I showed you the image in the right field.
So this is basically just
normal transmitted light.
Something else that we can do to our cells
is we can add in fluorescent tags
so that then our cells
have a color to them
when you shine the right
laser light at them.
So that's what these are.
So I'll turn the light off real quick
and switch over to the GFP channel.
So you can see here
that you basically have these cells
that have green in the circle like this.
So these are cells that have a GFP
or green fluorescent protein
attached to their mitochondria.
So basically, all of their mitochondria,
which produce the energy in the cells,
are labeled with GFP.
And so you can use these
to study the mitochondria.
For example, if you treat
the cells with a chemical
and it causes an increase or
decrease in this green color,
or that changes the patterning of them.
So yeah,
so that's how fluorescence can be used
in microscopy in cell culture.
So we're going to head back to main lab.
But while I'm getting resituated
if you guys can start poll number two.
- [Odaelys] On it.
- [Kelsey] Thank you.
- [Female Speaker] All right,
so I'm about to launch
the next poll question.
So the question is,
the fact that some cell
lines grow in suspension
while others attach to
the plate is based on,
and there are four different options.
I'll give you guys a
minute or two to answer.
- [Kelsey] And so I didn't
specifically go over the answer,
but think about what I showed you,
what type I showed you was suspension
and what type I showed you was adherent.
And see if you can reason your way.
- [Odaelys] And it's
okay if you don't know.
Just choose like the best
answer you think it is.
- [Kelsey] Yeah,
I honestly don't expect you
guys to know the correct answer.
This is just to see your reasoning
and see what your guess is,
and then we'll talk about it.
- [Odaelys] We have about 50% voted.
We're waiting on the other half.
- [Teacher] I do want
everyone to participate.
Again, it's based on your reasoning.
Please participate.
- [Odaelys] And I don't
know who answered what
so there's like no grade
associated with this whatsoever.
- [Teacher] Yeah.
And I'm looking through the chats
while you guys are answering.
- Yeah, so the question
about forever growing cells,
so that's kind of how you get cancer.
But some of these same genes
that you can put into your
cells 'cause you get cancer,
which is basically your
cells growing forever.
So a human living forever would
not really be as possible,
but the cells themselves, yeah,
that happens normally inside
your body if you get cancer.
- [Odaelys] Yeah, so it's like a tumor.
That's why you end up getting tumors
because the cells are
just continuously growing.
Awesome, so I'll give you 10 seconds.
10, nine, eight, seven, six,
five, four, three, two, one.
- Okay, so can you guys hear me?
I turned off my phone.
Okay.
So yeah, so I'm gonna share the results.
It looks like you guys were split
between whether they come from cancer,
normal tissue, or how they
normally grow in the body,
which actually are really good guesses
'cause basically I showed
you a colon cancer cell line
that grew adherently
and I showed you a red blood cell line
that grew in suspension.
And so I could see how normal
or cancer would be a good guess,
but the correct answer would be
how they normally grow in the human body.
So if I had a blood cancer
cell line, for example,
that would also grow in suspension.
So blood, it's suspended.
It's liquid inside of you
and the cells are kind
of just floating around,
as opposed to your colon,
your large intestine,
where the cells are growing attached.
Like you know, they're a sheet.
So the same thing if you had
like a skin cancer cell line.
That would grow adherently.
And so most cell lines grow adherently.
It's more the blood ones that
tend to grow in suspension.
But you just have to figure
out the best way to culture.
Every cell line's a little bit different.
Yeah, so does anybody have any questions
about anything I've shown
you with cell culture so far
or anything at all before I move on?
Okay.
So now, I'm gonna tell you guys.
- [Teacher] I'm sorry.
I just want to reinforce that, you know,
like you should definitely ask questions.
This is going to be as
interactive as you make it.
So again, definitely ask
your wondering questions
that you have.
- [Odaelys] Yeah,
you have a scientist at
your hands right now,
so take advantage of it.
- Yeah, and there are no stupid questions.
Like please, ask me anything
I guess science related,
but you know,
like I love to help.
So it looks like we have Mary Ellis.
Is that how you pronounce your name?
- [Mary] Yeah.
- So what's your question?
- [Mary] Okay, so isn't
cancer like when the cells
like have a miscommunication
and there's an error that happened?
- Yeah.
So it's often caused by
mutations in their DNA.
So when you have your DNA
that's being replicated
and you have your base pairs.
Instead of like putting in A, for example,
you end up with a G or something.
And that causes the gene to
now either lose its function
or gain extra functions.
And so this happens a few
different places in the DNA.
And together, they allow
the cells to proliferate,
to grow uncontrollably.
So they basically,
normally in your body,
there's a lot of regulation
of like, you know,
cells can grow and then they have to stop.
For example, like say you have a wound,
you need to regrow a bunch of skin cells
in order to fill in the wound.
But once you fill in the wound,
the skin cells stop growing.
But with cancer, there is no stop signal.
They basically have stopped listening
to the rest of the body.
So they just keep growing,
keep growing, keep growing.
And that's how you get
the big tumorous mass.
Did I answer your question?
- [Mary] Yeah, thank you.
- Yeah.
So, let's see.
I think we have a few in the chat.
So we have somebody who asked
about it is stem cell research
still relevant in the labs?
Yes, stem cell research
is extremely relevant.
So I'm mostly focused on cancer,
but I also do some research
looking at development,
so how red blood cells differentiate.
And so for me, I use not
quite a full stem cell,
but like a little bit more along the way.
And then I induce it
to differentiate into the red blood cell.
But a lot of what we're understanding
about how the body forms
basically from fertilization
is using stem cells.
We're also figuring out how
to potentially treat diseases.
So stem cells are still
very much a relevant field.
Let's see.
Have there been experiments
trying to take the forever
expanding properties of tumors
and re-purposing them?
So, Andy, would you mind telling me
exactly what you were trying to ask here?
- [Andy] Well, like,
you see how tumors can
expand forever, right?
So that would mean,
well, I'm assuming that that would mean
that like the tumor mass itself
can live forever, I guess.
Right?
So would they take like
some of those properties
of the tumor itself, and like for example,
that it can expand forever
or other properties that it may have,
and using them for other things,
or like, I don't know,
trying to use them for like
medicine or something like that?
- I mean, I think definitely
everything we learned
about how cancer works
helps us understand how things go normally
'cause you know, if something
is happening abnormally,
you can suddenly discover
certain signaling pathways
or interactions between different cells
that are relevant under
normal developmental
or normal cases.
And you can figure out
how they are relevant.
Same with certain other diseases
share properties with cancer.
And so if you can understand
how this one pathway is
misregulated in cancer,
you can understand
how it's misregulated
in this other disease.
But as far as like taking
their ability to replicate,
at least I'm not aware
of how that's been used
other than in the lab where
we have certain cell lines.
So like, if I took a sample of my blood
and I tried to grow it in the lab,
it would die pretty quickly
because the cells can't grow forever.
And also, I have to have
the right nutrients.
If I took the genes that
cancer uses to grow forever
and I put it into my blood cells
and tried to grow it in the lab,
then it would work a lot better.
And so it's more using it as a tool
in order to make these cell lines
that normally would have a limit,
you're able to grow them forever.
It's called immortalization
or transformation.
But I don't know about any cases
where it's been used beyond that,
but that doesn't mean that it's not.
It's just I'm not aware of it.
It looks like we have one final question.
So is chemotherapy supposed
to stop the cell growth?
Yeah.
So one of the hallmarks of cancer
is that it grows a lot faster
than all the other cells in your body.
And so chemotherapies
basically act upon that.
They prevent,
they kill cells that are
rapidly proliferating
more than they kill cells
that are not growing as fast.
And so the cancer is more hit,
but it's the reason why if
you treat with chemotherapy,
you lose your hair,
you can have gastrointestinal issues.
And that's because the cells
that are producing your
like hair follicles
or the cells in your gut
also rapidly proliferate.
And so you're hitting cancer,
but then you're also
hitting these other cells.
And then the rest of
the cells in your body
are kind of spared,
but that's why you have
these side effects.
It's very much a blunt
instrument for treating cancer
although it's done wonders
and was initially how we
started treating cancer.
Now, we're starting to be
a little bit more targeted
by using things that are
specific for the mutations
in that type of cancer,
or immunotherapy where you
take the person's immune system
and basically target the immune
system toward the cancer.
And yes, the hair does grow back
because once you remove the chemotherapy,
the cells are able to come back
because you have stem cells.
And potentially, the cancer can come back
depending on whether you
got rid of all of it or not.
- [Student] See, I was about to ask that.
So if one cancer cell remains,
it does come back, right?
- Yeah.
So if you can't get rid of
all of the cancer cells,
then it can come back.
And so that's part of the reason
why we try so many
different ways of treating.
So sometimes, somebody will get surgery,
and radiation, and chemotherapy
because the surgery removes
the bulk of the tumor.
Then the chemotherapy and the radiation
can help get those cells
that are remaining.
And if they get all the
cells that are remaining,
you're good.
If they don't,
which it's sometimes hard
to tell if they do or not,
then that's when you have
relapse down the line.
And so one of the major
focuses of cancer research
is trying to get better and better
at getting all of those cells,
targeting every last cell
before you stop the treatment,
although the treatment's limited.
You can't train somebody with chemotherapy
for the rest of their life
because the toxic side effects
and it possibly could have
other effects down the line.
It looks like Rosalind has a question.
- [Rosalind] Yes.
So I wanted to ask about breast cancer
'cause I have seen multiple articles
talk about that people of color,
well, women of color,
especially Black women and Hispanic women
are mostly affected by breast cancer.
And majority of the time,
Black women end up actually having more,
develop more aggressive
cancer and also stage,
which is why they're
diagnosed at a very young age
and also end up dying very
quickly compared to white women.
So I would like to know why maybe.
- So I'm not an expert in
breast cancer research.
From my understanding, I
don't think we fully know.
I think some of it has to do
with other genes that may be expressed
in Caucasian versus Black women.
But, yeah.
I mean, it's definitely a major issue.
Cancer is not one disease.
Basically every single
person who has cancer
has their own unique disease.
You know, like the
mutations are different.
The overall person is different.
'Cause you know,
I have certain alleles of genes
that someone else doesn't
and we don't entirely know how that plays
with the mutations in the cancer.
And so I'm sorry I don't
have a better answer
other than yes,
that is something we
are very much aware of
that there are these differences,
but we haven't yet fully
figured out what causes them.
Mary Ellis?
- [Mary] Okay.
Because cancer is a mutation to the cells,
is that why it's able to be passed on?
That's why if one of your family members
has like a certain type of cancer,
it's a higher chance that
you are gonna get it?
- So, sort of.
So there are different
contributors to cancer.
So there's environmental effects,
for example, smoking.
There are genetic effects
and then there's just
kind of random chance.
And so if I have a mutation,
for example, skin cancer
arises from moles.
So I have a mutation that
occurs in this mole on my arm
that causes me to get melanoma.
I'm not gonna pass that onto my children
'cause that mutation arose spontaneously
in this one skin cell.
However, if throughout my
entire body, I have a mutation,
for example, BRCA1, which is
associated with breast cancer,
and that's throughout my entire body,
which includes my germ cells, so my eggs.
When I have a child,
there's a possibility of
passing that on to my child.
And depending on the child's father,
what their genetics are,
then I can pass on an increased
risk of cancer to my child.
And so it basically depends
on where the mutation is.
If the mutation is somatic,
so it's only in normal body cells,
so not your egg or sperm cells,
it won't be passed on.
If it's throughout the entire body
or it affects your eggs and your sperm,
then you can inherit it.
Yes, and those are good points.
And then why do auto-immune diseases
attack the body's healthy cells
and how does it get treated?
So I'm not an expert on the immune system,
but from my understanding,
so you normally have your T-cells
and they're trained to
recognize self versus non-self.
And the ones that recognize self,
the ones that recognize
like me are weeded out,
they're killed.
And it's only the ones
that don't recognize self
that are able to continue
growing inside of your body.
And they recognize bacteria,
viruses, cancer cells.
But in some people,
the self recognizing
cells, for whatever reason,
are not killed in that same way.
And so then they are
able to attack your body
because they think that it's
a foreign invader basically
'cause T-cells don't know self for self,
they just know whatever
they're designed to target.
And so if whatever
they're designed to target
happens to be you,
they're gonna attack you the same way
that they would attack any other pathogen,
any other foreign invader.
So, any other questions?
These have all been really great.
I'm glad you guys
started asking questions.
Okay.
So I'm gonna start talking
about what I currently do.
I have about five minutes left.
- [Odaelys] I think, give or take.
- That's fine.
I mean, like I said,
I'd much rather we have this discussion.
So I guess before I do it,
if anybody has another question,
I would love to answer it.
If not, I'll just give
a very brief overview
of the two things that I study.
- [Odaelys] Is there's a specific time
that y'all have to leave?
- [Teacher] Yes.
Their next class starts
at, I think, it's 12:28.
- [Odaelys] Okay, cool.
That's in six minutes.
Okay, cool.
- Thank you.
- Oh, and before I forget,
I gave your teacher my email
address that goes in the bio.
Please feel free to contact me.
If you have questions
about like how to get into doing research,
if you have science questions,
I may not always know the answer,
but if I do, I would love to help.
So please email me with those
questions if you have them.
So, as I said before,
I study colon cancer.
So it's your large intestine,
cancers that arise there,
and kind of two major aspects of it.
The first is trying to study
the role of red blood cells in cancer.
And so, if you consider the cancer itself
as this small community of
cells that are all cancer cells,
there's also all these normal cells
that interact with this cancer,
that surround it, that are all around it.
And one of the cells
includes red blood cells.
And so we're interested to see
how red blood cells can
interact with the cancer cell
and promote the growth of the cancer.
So we think that they
might provide nutrients
and maybe other signals
that promote the growth.
You can go ahead.
I mean, I have like five more minutes.
Okay, sorry.
So, yeah.
So that's kind of the first thing
that I'm trying to study
is trying to see how the normal cells
outside of the cancer interacts
because we're becoming more and more aware
of the cancer micro environment,
this environment of normal cells
actually plays a very
important role in cancer.
It's not just the cancer
cells in isolation.
And potentially, we can,
instead of just trying to
target the cancer cells,
we can treat and try and
target these normal cells,
prevent these normal cells
from giving the cancers
whatever nutrients they need.
And that's another way we
can possibly try to treat
and cure a person's cancer.
And then the other project
that I'm focusing on
is looking at the role of glucose,
which is a sugar in colon cancer.
We know that cancer cells
actually metabolize glucose much faster
or much more rapidly
compared to normal cells.
And this has to do with how
they're metabolically set up.
And so we're trying to
see how in colon cancer,
glucose affects the signaling pathway
called the SAT pathway, a SAT3 pathway,
and how that promotes
the growth of the tumor.
And so we can understand
how glucose leads to
activation of this pathway,
which promotes the growth of the cancer.
Then maybe we can, once again,
come up with new and better
ways to target colon cancer
'cause colon cancer is one of these ones
where we can screen for it
and we can treat it early, which is good.
And that's part of the reason
why it's highly curable.
And then there's other people
that whatever we've tried to this point,
it just doesn't work.
And so we're always looking
for a new understanding of cancer
so that we can have a new therapy to try.
And so I'm not involved in
the creation of the therapies,
but I'm trying to have
a better understanding,
so that way, other people
can take that understanding
and convert it into therapies.
So yeah, that was a very quick overview
of kind of what I do in lab.
So I guess before you guys have to go,
any last questions, comments?
I'd love to talk about anything else
that people are interested in.
Okay, well, I mean.
Oh, do I enjoy working in the lab?
Yeah, I very much enjoy how doing research
combines being hands-on,
like I get to work with my hands,
but I also am working with my brain.
I'm planning experiments,
I'm thinking through results,
but it's not just sitting in
front of a computer all day.
I enjoy actually doing things,
even if it's just transferring liquid
from one container to another container,
which is actually doing something,
but at the time, I can't see.
But then I get this really cool result
and then I get to interpret it.
And so, obviously,
COVID has affected working in a lab.
Now, we all wear masks
and we have to keep our distance
and a only certain number
of people in the room,
but yeah,
overall, I think research
is a really cool career
and I'm really glad that I get to do it.
And I'm really glad that
I've had the opportunities
I have had that led me on this path.
Yeah, so if you want to get
started in a science field,
so like I said, I was fortunate
as a high school student
to get to work in a lab one summer
and there are some programs
where high school students
can join a lab for the summer
and they learn.
And I guess, I can mostly
speak from biology.
I can't speak of other sciences
'cause that's not what
my experience is in.
But I think you either
as a high school student
or as an undergrad,
a lot of people do it as an undergrad,
getting into a lab either via the summer
or during the semester,
there's a whole bunch
of different programs
at various research
institutions at universities,
applying for those.
Or once you go to college,
like you're in biology 101,
you can go talk to your professor
and be like, hey, I want to do research.
Like, do you have any suggestions
on who I should talk to,
or you know, what lab I
might be able to join?
Also, as was pointed out in the chat,
RockEDU has a lot of great programs
that introduce students to research.
But I think a lot of it is
either trying to find a program
or just sending an email asking someone.
That was how I got my first
research experience in the lab
was I emailed this one professor,
and I was like, hey,
can I come work for you?
And he didn't have room,
but he passed my email on to somebody else
and they did have room.
And so I ended up in a lab that way.
And it was such a really
cool, great experience.
I think the earlier you
can start, the better,
but it's also never too late to start.
So, I mean, it's all about exploring.
I've done research in a
bunch of different topics.
I did plant research for a
year while I was an undergrad
and I quickly learned that I
didn't want to study plants.
And so I think just trying things,
figuring out what field
you're interested in.
For me, it's cancer biology.
I like trying to understand
how these cells take what
happens during normal development
and manipulate it,
and turn it to their own uses.
But for other people,
it could be immunology.
It could be material science.
It could be physics.
Just finding what research,
if that's the career you want.
There's also so many other careers.
So just try things, I think,
would be my biggest advice.